the projects you have coming up and
you're teaming up with
army hammer and shotgun wedding yeah
everything has been so fluid with with
everything in the theaters
less than two months later army has
suddenly quit shotgun wedding with
production set to take place
imminently there's no word on who will
be recast alongside jlo
army's decision comes days after a
series of unverified instagram messages
allegedly sent from him
leaked online they include fantasies of
rape
cannibalism and violence he released a
defiant and profanity-lay statement
telling e.t
quote i'm not responding to these
expletive claims but in light of the
vicious online attacks against me
i cannot in good conscience now leave my
children for four months to
shoot a film army is in the middle of a
divorce from wife of 10 years elizabeth
chambers
a source tells e.t chambers is quote in
complete shock
and sickened by the various claims and
does not want their kids to be
traumatized by
everything going on e.t last spoke to
army back in october to promote the
netflix film
rebecca well first thing let's just do a
little wellness check how's everybody
doing oh you know
just living the dream i mean someone's i
don't know who knows
he played a husband trying to hide a
violent secret from his wife
she was bloated decomposing her arms
ripped off and there was nothing left of
her face
well this of course was pre paparazzi
but we wanted to know everything about
him and his personal life
army what do you make of that we're so
fascinated with your individual life it
sucks it makes you like a commodity and
not a human
back to jlo e.t can confirm she will
join lady gaga wednesday to perform at
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
[Music]
gaga will sing the national anthem while
jennifer will perform during the capital
ceremony which will be protected by 20
000 national guardsmen after last week's
violent riot j lo also is elle's cover
girl and says
she has no plans to reschedule her
wedding to a-rod anytime
soon quote we canceled it and since then
we haven't really talked about it